le conseil des ministres de ce matin a
permis à madame ségolène royal ministre
de la famille de présenter toute une
série de mesures destinées à faciliter
l'adoption des enfants principalement à
propos des enfants venus de l'étranger
il s'agit avant tout de
professionnaliser encore un peu plus des
associations qui aident les couples dans
leur démarche en guérit ni d encre
c'était le mois dernier les familles
d'adoption manifestaient contre le
projet de réforme de ségolène royal
jusqu'à présent ses parents adopté en
démarche individuelle
autrement dit ils constituaient une
demande auprès de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et pouvait se rendre seul sur
place pour adopter ce que le
gouvernement propos c'est d'imposer aux
familles de passer désormais par des
organismes mandatés par l'état
la france est en difficulté par rapport
à l'adoption internationale que les
adoptions ont tendance à diminuer alors
que dans les autres pays européens
notamment le nombre d'adoptions augmente
donc je me suis interrogé sur les
raisons de ce blocage les raisons de ce
blocage c'est qu'en france 60% des
familles adoptent de façon individuelle
et alors que dans les autres pays
européens toutes les familles passent
par des organismes agréés
ces organismes vont recevoir de grosses
subventions 610000 euros en contrepartie
ils devront être plus professionnelle et
plus transparent quant à l'argent
demandé aux adoptants pour les familles
il reste d'autres inquiétudes ce sont
les critères de sélection qu'imposent
ces organismes par exemple vous avez
déjà des enfants qu'ils soient
biologiques ou adoptez donc priorité est
donnée à d'autres
un écart d'âge entre les parents
adoptants les enfants qui pourraient
adopter
il ya même des critères de revenus qui
sont imposés par certaines associations
et qui font que
aujourd'hui beaucoup déposé dossier par
démarche individuelle réformer mais
aussi rassuré ségolène royal a promis
aux familles que les critères de
sélection ne seront plus imposées par
les organismes mais plutôt par les pays
d'origine